today podcast is sponsored by manscape
check out their ultra premium collection
it's a cleaning routine for more than
just your balls
the kit has you fully covered head to
toe
and when you feel clean you feel
confident like me the baddest man around
the ultra premium collection includes
manscapes deodorant for your armpits
it also includes a hydrating body spray
if you have tattoos or dry skin
there's body wash and the two-in-one
shampoo as well
all products are cruelty paraben and dye
free
clean yourself off after a hard workout
like i do with the ultra premium
collection
you'll be smelling great all day long
also don't forget the flagship manscape
long mower 4.0
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code hotboxing.manscape.com
again that's 20 off free shipping with
the code hotbox and at manscape.com
being a badass now comes in the bottle
thanks to manscape
yes sir
so what happened
is you know i got first got locked up
and i wanted to spend five years in the
juvenile system okay that was fun though
you got your cookies and [ __ ] what you
get you get you get three meals and then
at night you get a snack yeah
no no no no this is what they don't know
oh
at night time like hour before you ready
to be you go back to the childhood they
had the snacks the juices the chocolate
milkshakes yeah that wasn't the cookies
the chocolate milks they had no they had
all type of stuff when i was it's
cooking
but didn't you do this
you played listen you played listen you
played i don't know what we did
so now the whole time you and they're
happy you don't understand that they
prepare you for the penitentiary
[Music]
yo what's good everybody welcome back to
hot boxing with mike tyson
i'm bash the co-host and we got wallow
and gilly here today
oh gang a million dollar worth of game
they got a jalen ramsey on shout out to
um uh young thug kevin gates meek mills
damian lillard damian lillard kevin
garnett yeah
everybody and they're [ __ ] different
because they like travel to them like
they had a little kid that's what i
wanted i want to go on location to
france or somewhere italy that's
something funny she's not stuck in the
office of [ __ ] dog
all right so let's talk [ __ ] guys come
on what the [ __ ] you doing man i'm
boxing with now good mike baby we hot
boxing with mike but mike listen when
you saw this this fake tough guy and he
was on his on instagram what did you
think which one
this one right here
i don't know i don't know i thought he
wanted to get shot or some [ __ ]
he's by himself with the [ __ ] talking
bad [ __ ] like he got a thousand [ __ ]
behind him but he's by himself
so yeah that's how i rolled up
coincidentally i've been shot a few miss
shots
[ __ ] [ __ ] no [ __ ]
i know you talking about your [ __ ] you
know
that's absolutely new man you know what
i realized in my life
um
when i brought that energy i brought
that heat came behind it mm-hmm but when
i try to do like in and like me now
it doesn't come to me you know when you
bring it to your energy
attracts yeah yeah your energy i don't
have that energy anymore you know when
we was younger
growing up in you know in north
philadelphia the streets of north philly
where we came from
it was just like a certain culture
what is that
if
listen you ain't had a right listen if
you ain't shot nobody somebody took your
chain and you ain't come back and shot
them you're a [ __ ] yeah yeah your food
now yeah you [ __ ] oh yeah
you don't even want to shoot nobody but
you know if you don't what's going to
happen yeah just like the wolves all of
us going to turn on you absolutely we're
good people
you know we'll die for this guy but once
he let that happen we all turn on him
like wolves that's how that [ __ ] be out
there man it's just
it's just crazy man you know yeah and
and and wallow you know mike he went to
jail with 17. yeah you put it in he did
20 years and then came home at 37. yeah
listen your story listen
like this these guys look like you
ain't no dudes but you don't have to get
so harmless and stuff
i am did you work that critique up to be
successful you guys seem so harmless
don't look at this guy did a day in
prison no it's like you go out and you
go out of the dumpster you know how you
go through that phase when you're young
you just love dumb [ __ ] because in the
ghetto the ghetto glorify and amplify
and they respect dumb [ __ ] and if you
ain't bringing that dumb [ __ ] it's like
oh you're a [ __ ] go to work be a nut if
you ain't selling no dope if you ain't
shooting nobody if you ain't doing none
of that and that's what we taught that's
what we're educated about cause you
think about it mike when we kids and
we're in the ghetto
and you sitting on the step and you see
the dude pulled up in the bins of the
cadillac and he got a nice clothes on
smelling good the chain he going to pick
up the most beautifulest girl in the
neighborhood so you as a kid you saying
you looking at him get her then you
looking at the neighbors in the in the
community the older ladies
everybody respect this guy but their own
respective dude is coming home from work
dirty everyday so you're like i got to
be a street [ __ ] unless i you preach
into the choir i mean so that's how they
should be why because no why cause none
of them little [ __ ] with that chin
nobody [ __ ] it though i want to be like
that
mm-hmm
now and for us you know now that we're
older it's all about giving games yeah
that street game is vicious
it's vicious and the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
the [ __ ] it'll [ __ ] you all the way up
and i had you just like man
how you in that [ __ ] cell on
that graveyard you know
and if it's certain situations that you
go through
and uh you know
you don't develop a relationship with
god and you know start seeing what's the
right ways then you you're gonna end up
where you're gonna end up at as i get
older i develop a relationship with god
all right be all be honest with you my
expiration date is coming up soon i'm
trying to make sure the meeting is right
i'm not trying to find my way i think i
haven't given money away lately but you
know
subconsciously i'm trying to buy my way
in there too that meeting is a
[ __ ] when you get older you
people walk up on you and ask you how
you doing you start saying [ __ ] like
blessed by the best
you know because the reality of it is
hold of you 26
26.
just you know saying nothing don't
happen you know we i'm 45 he's 54 55
he's 42. we probably lived half our life
already it's probably 60 percent you
know what i'm saying
when you think about it might be 80
because
what's the chances of me living the 90
as we get older i ain't [ __ ] burger
king all the
time out chill out
we're going crazy we feel crazy
as we get older the age we get closer to
our past than we do to our future mm-hmm
we get closer to our mother farther than
aunt than we do to our children niece
and nephew right
and vice versa
but they get older they're ready that
they get they're closer to us than they
are to their own children and that's how
life goes as you get older you're closer
to your path
honestly going off of what you said
wallow your story is amazing
let's hear it yeah so
if i just correct me if i'm wrong you
know obviously you know you served your
time then you studied business you just
started studying studying studying all
types of different different revenues of
businesses business and stuff like that
then you ended up becoming like a huge
motor motivational speaker start talking
at like universities penn state right
yeah a bunch of bunch of them
blew up on instagram blew up on the
internet you and gilly uh are obviously
cousins and you all produce million
dollars worth of game and now it's just
blowing up to what it's done but can you
talk about kind of your experience and
why you were in the pen like how did
that come come in your mind like
i feel like it's easy to kind of like
succumb to your circumstances right yeah
i actually spent more time
in institutions in my life than i did
free i first got locked up june 30 of
1990. i was on my birthday
i first got locked in mine's june 21st
okay
that's why we warriors that's why we
winners but that's another story so the
bikes are worried no no no no no no no
no what the [ __ ] you mean i'm a woman no
no we want we want people to see that
we're warriors
more like then we want people to see
that way warriors right but you was
really a warrior no no no no no i want
[ __ ] i've seen you no i know i know i
know and i project that to them i want
them to see and feel that i'm a warrior
but not necessarily that i am yeah yeah
but i seen you i i witnessed personally
when you knocked trouble burping cow
i'm talking this weed right here it's
hitting like how you was hitting when tr
remember when trey burke went down and
then got up and then went down again but
in all reality that's fleeting
it's gone you could never get it back no
you can't come on so i got something
here with you and you're my future now
all right yeah and that was my path uh
but but your passes will make you who
you are today
our path can't dictate our futures like
that now you know who i am today
you know what happens if only if it
dictated my future i'm this way because
of my path then my past went my pastor
shouldn't be able to beat me
that's deep i should be i should be able
to enter my path as i before as i die
but they shouldn't be able to have any
control of me while i'm living life
deep so what happened
is you know i got first got locked up
and i wanted to spend five years in the
juvenile system okay that was fun though
you got your cookies and [ __ ] what you
get you get you get three meals and then
at night you get a snack yeah
no no no no this is what they don't know
oh
i don't know if they did it for you back
in the day but like at nighttime like
hour before you ready to bid you go back
to the childhood they had the snacks the
juices the chocolate milkshakes yeah
that was the cookies the chocolate milks
they had no they had all type of stuff
when i was because it's
so now the whole time you in there happy
you don't understand that they preparing
you for the penitentiary because you're
getting use and this [ __ ] is normal to
you it's because it's becoming listen
it's becoming normal to you yeah it's
becoming normal to you because you just
like oh [ __ ] this ground yeah i go back
to the jubilee joint [ __ ] yeah yeah so
when you go home you get a case again
you go back down there you always got
like it's always like an older woman
there's somebody there that treats you
like you they son
you
as soon as you get back into the shoes
you come back in mr brown's like you
back again boy and you like yeah miss
brown i mean she make sure you hook you
up that's how that should be but i kept
going to juvenile city but i spent five
years in and out and then when i turned
17 i got locked up for two armed
robberies and two firearms our leashes
got a total of 19 that had the 52 years
okay and uh
i i went in there
and my alarm clock came on during the
journey of like yo man there's more to
life than this [ __ ] mm-hmm cause i'm
seeing i'm in there i'm going in there
i'm and i always used to be around the
ogs dudes like a lot of dudes i was
around they got 30 40 years in prison
yeah older dudes from you know black
mafia philadelphia whatever it may be
yeah and i just used to sit around them
and soak life up and just try to you
know listen i listened more than i
talked and i learned a lot but i
realized that it was more to me to life
than doing some street [ __ ] cause it's
jail [ __ ] i'm seeing people die yeah i'm
saying people uh you know they can't be
out there to take care of their kids and
all that [ __ ] their mothers
deteriorating yeah so i was like yo man
it's more life than this [ __ ] and i just
started educating myself and reading
more like i didn't know how to read and
none of that but i learned in juvie how
to read because i wanted to read the
easy magazine and i went over to the
school building i was like yo can i
because before then i used to go to
school when they said make it and eight
times was my turn to read i'd be like i
gotta go to the bathroom yeah but the
teacher caught me one day and i i was
embarrassed i stopped like going then
when i wanted to learn i learned and i
just started reading when i got to the
penitentiary and uh it opened my mind up
it was my way to explore the world cause
the only thing i knew was the ghetto
but reading and watching stuff in jail
like anthony bourdain no reservations
parts are known yeah i was able to
travel the world through my imagination
the show and that's what really helped
me you know that's amazing yeah
i i read something about you using
google a lot or how google became your
name no what happened was a dude a young
guy
cause cause when people used to come to
prison yeah if i knew mike yeah i mean
and his son came to prison he was like
yo go see wallow and i see he's like yo
mike my dad like damn what's up young
again you know give me set up some
commissary some cosmetics [ __ ] like that
but i will always interrogate them
because i was fascinated with the free
world because when you go to prison
you're trapped in a world that don't
exist no more so when a young cat had to
come i interrogate them for days i'd be
like yo what's this what's that what's
this and they'd just be telling me [ __ ]
about what's going on so when the kid
told me about google
i'm like what because he told me hey i
could type your name and i found out hey
i see how the [ __ ] you could take my
name and i've been in jail this time
yeah that [ __ ] don't make no sense i
thought he was lying to me oh yeah so i
would write it down i would write it
down in my book of life cause i had this
thing i still got called the book of
life where everything somebody told me i
write it down like i didn't know nothing
about relationships and none of that but
people would tell me i'm like okay so
you live with your girl yeah i was
living with it we went on where did you
all go oh we want a trip yeah how much
did the plane ride cost i would because
it was like it was new it was new i mean
i don't know
the only thing i knew how to be a
criminal and be on some street [ __ ] i
didn't know nothing about life so i
would just write it down in the book of
life so when i was in jail i wanted to
get my hand on on a hot
uh ipod touching a wireless hot spot so
when i'm in my cell i type the google
[ __ ] up yeah when i for the first time
because i'm looking through my book
everything i i type it up i'm in my cell
high i got the curtain up i typed in
google popped up i dropped the phone i
thought the fez was on me i said oh [ __ ]
there's some scary [ __ ] how do you know
my name is the obstacle it was scary so
you know you and then i just started
learning more i just was in there
learning and learning and learning and
reading [ __ ] learning and just listening
to the og's and uh
you know cause there was this one over
here named shoes
uh they said they they thought he had
cancer but he wound up having aids and
that was my old guys to push him around
the yard and go run and get his
cigarettes get you know certain [ __ ]
they told him not to smoke he'd like
[ __ ] them give me a cigarette because i
go get him from the medical from the
hospital you know they've got like a
hospital like cells in there so i'm
pushing him away
he was an old gangster from philly and
he told me i seen him the night before
he died because i ain't even know he was
but he he grabbed my arm and i was
talking to him because he'd be laughing
all this [ __ ] smoking a cigarette in his
bed he said do me a favor man he said
when you get out of jail live he said i
never lived my life i lived for
everybody in the hood i ain't never go
nowhere i ain't never do nothing i never
live he said just go out there and live
man when you get out don't come back
here what did that mean to you it it
meant a lot to me because
what was living how do you live your
life no what he said was to me he said
explore basically like get out there and
explore because he said i lived my whole
life in the ghetto i went to ghetto jail
ghetto jail he said i kept going back
down the way he said the world is bigger
than down the way the world is bigger
than your neighborhood and he's just and
i just like
i was like damn man he just said man
just please man just just go see things
go field things just be free that's real
and and and i come back the next day and
when i came back the next day he was
gone
and they lied to me cause i came in the
hospital because they always see me
coming they see me walking they know i'm
gonna get shoes take him around the yard
cause your time take him in the yard get
him you know what i mean all that type
of stuff and they was like oh uh he had
to go somewhere he'd be back the lady
ain't gonna tell me so i came back like
two three times and then i waited to the
shift change and when the shift changed
the
nurse was like oh he left us last night
i said well they took him to the hot
when they went to another huh like what
she was like she's seeing she was like
he going
i was [ __ ] up because that was like my
he was somebody that i talked to eight
day and you know i was so close to him
and he used to tell me all the stories
and it was just
his laugh all day yeah but i never
forgot what he told me and when i and
when it was my time to come home i said
i got to live you know i just got to be
free and stop worrying about you know
[ __ ] what people think and i just got to
live my life you know it's real because
it seemed like my whole life i was i was
operating based off of the opinions and
others and what i was supposed to be
because of my zip code and my
environment no you got to be a real
[ __ ] you got to be this and i ain't
know that i could be be somebody else in
that and that you know and [ __ ] change
for me man my whole life i looked
outside the box even when i was getting
arrested as a kid
i was outside the box
and everything
all i got um all the guys that um my
juvenile time
50 60 years yeah
everybody went to jail it seemed like
anybody made it to the penitentiary
that's that's a buddha life to be
involved with even if you're not
involved being a parent being somebody's
sister brother mother uncle
dealing with that
you know it's crazy i really understand
that life man that that's almost um
nothing's impossible but that's close to
it
you know
to be uh um what you what i always call
my a bad [ __ ] i seen the night
yeah the the uh alarm clock came on when
i was in prison my name is death [ __ ]
yeah no that is no it really is it's
we when we was growing up we you know we
was doing major figures yeah that's us
we was doing robberies and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying wallow always was in the
wrapping i wasn't in the rap and i was
into playing basketball okay you know
what i'm saying so i actually was in
college okay you know i had a i had an
apartment with with a woman you know
what i mean i come home from school i
get with cuz
we go do what we do i go back up to
college you know what i'm saying
so
for me you're a smart [ __ ] huh yeah you
know yeah yeah yeah you educate like me
[ __ ] just keeps it in the hood though
yeah and and wallow said something you
know one one day that he was like cuz
when you really think about it like
you was on some some some crazy [ __ ]
like because you would be up at the
college yeah and i went to a
90-something percent white college
cabrini university yeah i mean i played
basketball there and you wouldn't go up
there they don't have no idea what you
do who you are you cool with everybody
they love you and then you leave from
there and come right back to the hood
and we go do robberies and then you
leave and go right back up to college
like yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
but like how'd you no keep it a buck so
like doing that how'd you like
how are you able to do that well i got
kicked out of college because during the
armed robbery during the summer august
22nd 1996 but right before we was about
to go back to college
we
we was in the middle of doing an armed
robbery and one of my homies got killed
and uh it was on the front of the daily
news and uh i got kicked out of college
and then that's really when i started
rapping yeah like you know what i mean
and he always rapped you know what i'm
saying i i didn't really grow up what's
happening here though that was just
yeah this was one of our videos from
back in the day that we dropped was a
number two rap single in the country
dropped this in 1999 okay
yeah
and you and if i'm correct you wrote you
ghost wrote for a little wayne i grew up
i don't really talk about that no more
man i've been talking about that for
like
20 years right honey but i mean that's
writers all across the world who
sit around and they write them hot songs
and they deliver them to the artist and
because they really get no credit they
get paid but they get no credit this is
listen a little weight this white guy
for me to call him an invisible man this
guy broke michael jackson oh what
what what he could write no one knows
who he is that's why they call them the
invisible man bad real yo michael
jackson yeah um
thriller he's badass
lady of my life for this it's a call
he's a cold guy hmm sure no one knows
who he is yeah he's a bad [ __ ]
though yeah the reasonable man yes the
invisible man the myth
the legend you know what i mean hit
records he probably wrote man yeah
white boy too
r b all the [ __ ] you got history
history
white
characters that was the invisible man
right now it's real pretty real you know
no cat but no that's amazing that you
did that too for wayne i mean [ __ ]
that's just this legendary to me i mean
he's one of the best movies
i mean for football huh
um i like kevin gates like the new guy
yeah kevin gates
rob wade
those are the new guys out there that i
like but the old school guy is always
tupac and public enemy public enemy
yeah although big just the old school
guys you know i mean
um
what's homeboy named keith keith murray
those
very awesome very confrontational
rappers i like very confrontational cool
j those guys just get in your [ __ ]
face
who is they don't do that too much now
a lot of people got killed all that
stuff but everybody is everywhere pretty
respectful now instead of these young
other young guys but who who shot um
little bootsy up and killed his boy emma
morey p i interviewed mo p and him
before no three number three right
he's a nice person you think that
there's somebody out there that wants to
kill him i mean
you know
a lot of these youngins be beefing in
the streets man
and i i really don't be understanding it
you know what i mean because it's like
you'll get rappers that
you you make it to a certain level when
you got to understand that that's a
blessing um
that's a blessing because everybody rap
everybody played basketball everybody
played football don't look at it like
that what i'm saying so when you when
god put a blessing on you to lift you up
amongst everybody
and
help you get out the ghetto for you to
make it and then still want to act like
you in the same conditions that you was
in when
it's just be unbelievable to me and it'd
be like young as y'all got too much to
live for people taught them how to make
money
when people didn't take that how do they
exist
people i could die for somebody in love
i can't live for them
that's the little don't like right when
we was coming up though
a lot that helped me change was when
you know shout out to tony draper you
know he gave me my advanced money when i
signed the suave house my first advance
money
and i was like
damn i really could do this [ __ ] yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah give you
that gave you that so now
armed robberies and that type that's not
even yeah because it's like wait hold on
i got a chance to make money off of
doing this i'm really seeing money off
of rapping yeah
i don't want [ __ ] to do with the streets
i'm good i suppose like
so when so that was your that was kind
of your life
and he and then walla was in jail that
time yeah okay and that's when that
clicked wow walla was in jail when that
video came out okay so damn and he he
came up with the name because wallow was
in the rap
i wasn't in the rap so when wallow came
to me on the rap [ __ ] i was like hey you
tripping man like i'm trying to go yeah
i'm trying to rob these [ __ ]
man what the [ __ ] is he talking about
man yeah but
he used to be like real passionate about
that [ __ ] like cuz [ __ ] out
here making real money off this [ __ ] you
gotta understand he's three years
younger than me
so i might be 17 and he's 14.
and he telling me this [ __ ] but
even at 14 15 you wouldn't have never
thought wallow was that young yeah
because wallow got a tattoo in his neck
you know
fbtm [ __ ] [ __ ] take money was no 14
15 year old kid running around with no
tattoo on their neck
talk about you know what i'm saying he
was always tall
everybody hung with was older so you
know what i mean you would have never
thought wallow was yeah you know really
into that but
you know he was really passionate about
that music [ __ ]
i said guy like you could be the first
thing you could start interviewing your
friends in prison
stuff like that you have the world's
heroes problems here it's case out
you help people like that too i like
matching you can go in there and talk to
them um
[ __ ] junior black mafia [ __ ]
and help them get them up give them a
platform for people to see
who they really are
instead of the stigma
you know and you can connect with some
of you that's what that's what that's
what gets us in trouble
yeah that's that's that's a good idea
that's good [ __ ] so obviously y'all
did it with barstool how did that come
about now that's that i feel like that
was a huge power move too by y'all but
also y'all own all y'all do everything
yourself
you own your own [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah um
what happened was
we was we was just doing our thing
independently we was on number one on
the charts a lot and uh spotify came to
us
they was going back and forth with
spotify then bar student came and we we
had
it made sense to us in income you want
to buy percentage of your no no we
wasn't doing i mean you want to give it
away yeah so we said we're gonna we're
gonna keep ownership of our company and
just partner up with them so it was like
we just gonna get with somebody that
really got partnerships with brands and
all yeah and that's what we did and it
was just great you know it was a great
place to be you know we
it's like uh they they understand what
we're doing they stay out of our way you
know what i mean we get busy yeah that's
a big i feel that's the biggest thing
having that ownership you feel me
especially as black men well that's huge
that's huge because you know
we're gonna try to
take some and try to you know give you a
little something i don't know how it is
when those deals and stuff like that
how uh they try to give you advance but
you know you really don't own anything
or something like that so it's just dope
to see y'all owning that [ __ ] and just
running with it keep killing it ross and
the people that get the van they don't
want to do this [ __ ] they don't want to
run the company
you know
this real work yes
it is and i really enjoy it i really
enjoy
uh getting you know setting the cameras
up setting the mics up traveling going
to different cities yeah taking the
conference room turning into a studio
real quick five minutes so you know
that's what i really like right i really
like you know you know setting up the
mics here and i love it yeah i mean it's
something that i enjoy to do and seeing
it done when it's finished has edited it
up yeah and we push you know upload and
it come on premiere and that show come
out and people love it so hey what was
your favorite episode who your favorite
interview
i mean i'm i'm you know i'm a sports guy
so
probably you know kevin durant or you
know floyd mayweather yeah
cause i'm a sports guy you know what i
mean but my my my favorite episode
is about to be with mike tyson
beauty what are you afraid of
um i'm afraid of one of my biggest
things i'm i'm afraid of
of of getting killed by a black man yeah
i'm afraid of being in the in a ghetto
and then and somebody knocked me out
take me out of here
just because of like because i don't
[ __ ] with nobody just because of you
know they just
they don't know right and they don't
know what's going on in their life and
they just knock me off i don't care
about too much [ __ ] out but but that's
that's one of my biggest fears you know
and probably dying alone you know dying
by myself like no family no you know
[ __ ] like that
how about you bob my biggest fear
probably ain't death is probably uh
dying slow really you know what i mean
like of cancer oh sickness you know what
i mean we're just
you know what i mean you got to sit
there and deteriorate and your family
got to watch you and
that's probably my only fear about you
mike me yeah
i don't know being homeless living you
know living in the streets again
going back to brownsville scares me yeah
my mom would probably be
just family
you know doing what i'm doing and the
next thing you know i just i'm not
afraid of brownsville but just
the fact that i'm back mm-hmm i totally
understand that i always um look at all
everything that's
that's a blessing too
you know for me you know
the wake up is the win
mm-hmm you know if i woke up this
morning and i'm healthy man
if you win the morning you win the day
yes
gilly so uh
so i remember i saw a video that went
viral of you
uh supporting shout out to dion
the story for dion
dion sanders you were you were at the
university yes cheering them all yes
and that boy that boy that boy scored a
touchdown i don't know who what player
was exactly shot to him though and you
celebrated with him in the end zone can
you talk about that moment
well
when we got there you know we did they
told us you know
dion sanders yeah we went down to
jackson state you know we go down there
and we support the the you know jackson
state you know and support the honors
college [ __ ]
you know so
we go down there and uh they tell us you
know you got to stay behind the white
line you know we we dress like the
coaches yeah
and
it's a fumble he picked the ball up as
you see how they had it on sportscenter
as you see i'm running down i never come
past the white line never running down
the side
with the player let's go
what game is this let's go this this was
jackson's
football game versus somebody i don't
know i don't know
like the really dominant black school
yeah yeah yeah
dion sanders coaches for them now yeah
so
we we run down parallel to the end zone
together when he when he scores i say
yeah youngin
he threw me
as he threw me the football and i caught
it mike i only know how to do one thing
i see tom brady give his offensive
lineman to football they spiked the [ __ ]
yes sir so i spiked it at the end zone
and got a penalty and you
he come to me he like i'm like yo what
the [ __ ] did you just do that for he
told me something he gave me the boss
here cuz
you threw the ball in the endzone you're
not playing
why would well he gave me the ball so it
was i said that's my fault next thing
you know the ref said tiana don't even
know what happened 15-yard penalty
on jackson state's [ __ ] oh
diaz had never come back again
for four
games
[ __ ] was crazy man but i went back
though to the bowl game after my full
game suspension yeah
so shout out to coach brown yeah shout
out to coach who's your favorite uh
philly boxers like did you what what's
that you know in this
book you
danny garcia you got to get bernard you
got to give danny uh-huh but now he's
not fighting no more he's just a
legendary fighter you know you got to
shout them out first and foremost
because they from the city yeah but
right now mm-hmm there's a kid named
stephen fulton junior yes
he has two belts at 122 pounds what is
that pool boy step boy steph he got two
belts yes sir unified champion right now
what pound 122.
okay and it's a k
ron boots ennis yeah he's bad too he's a
monster the future of of boxing remember
i told you guys that them two kids you
believe that
yes my brother-in-law he believes the
same thing yes i i think he needs to be
tested a little more
who he need to fight a guy like him
um
he needs to fight a guy at um danny
garcia
it needs to be the championship of
philadelphia
for the welterweight championship of
philadelphia you need to be in
philadelphia i held them vague because
you got to pay that philly tax it's
going to kill them okay so you got to go
to florida either vegas the place where
people are going to give you the arena
you won't have to pay for it
that's why they kill that's why they're
killing the game and vegas over there
because they're giving you the money
they're paying you to come there yeah
you paying them to fight there right
incredible that's crazy right one thing
i know about that kid though cause i
know him since he was like 12 years old
yes
he eats
shits
sleeps
dreams
walk
run
boxing his dad was a professional boxer
both his brothers
and still don't make it yeah he may
either no but he but he's because he's
who he is yes he
he is who he
is since
because my son boxed since he was six
all the way up to 18. so i used to take
my son to all the gyms
everybody in philly knew
you want some real work
go down the bozies go down to that
dungeon
don't no no no no no i want to hear you
went over here and you got some work i
don't want to hear you went over here
and got some work go down to that
dungeon because when you go down to that
dungeon they ain't got [ __ ] near that
work if you think that why don't won't
they have that fight that'd be the
biggest fighter philadelphia uh i think
they i think
the relationship is too close oh ain't
nothing about relationship we're
fighters we're trying to yeah i know but
i think the relationship is you know
that that's not a professional fighter
the professor
if they had a good relationship they
should fight because they're going to
make each other rich um that's a good
that's a good that's a good man
i'm not going to fight that good
relationship i'm going to give him two
million dollars so i'm not going to
fight just because i love him i love you
he ain't no he don't know when next time
he's on your two million dollar fight a
million dollar fight
friends help each other to make money
yes they do
so what are your favorite moments of my
mic in the ring
i mean so many of them yeah i know you
know what are you talking about
what do you mean
you know what it is too many of them you
know what i mean
you know what i mean i think he became
the youngest champion ever crazy man you
know kante said no it's a new name for
ego
legacy
legacy
yeah that's the new word for ego that's
deep that's deep
my legacy
who the [ __ ] can't about my legacy when
i'm there who what's that about you want
people to still think wonderful about
you even though when you're alive you're
the principal and you're dead they put
statues up for you
a lot of [ __ ] get praised after
they die a guy could be a piece of [ __ ]
all his life and once he died he becomes
the thing oh man i miss john but john
was a piece of [ __ ] he beat you out of
money never paid you back
hitting on your wife and john you
weighed yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's funny how that worked
definitely does make people more
i don't know death makes people that's
make people
sympathetic
that's what it is you know what it's
sympathetic i did a post on instagram
remember what i said i'm not talking to
the white families because i don't know
if y'all do this but to my black
families and then i said let's stop the
[ __ ]
every time a [ __ ] die we go to the
funeral and start lying and [ __ ] he was
about to go back to school know the [ __ ]
he wasn't johnny was hustling
and slamming
johnny was a piece of [ __ ] but he was
our piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you feel what i'm saying like
let's keep it real everybody in here no
johnny [ __ ]
johnny was awesome
johnny owned everybody money everybody
everybody owes everybody money it should
be more of a of some jokes going on like
that we want to see johnny go but he but
he he burnt me burnt my mom out of rent
money maybe he took them by my money
yeah
saying all this [ __ ] that everybody in
the crowd know ain't true he was an
amazing man
man of god
like johnny had his problem but he was
trying to he was straightening him out
no he wasn't johnny bought some cool
came last night he was not straightening
it out he was going deeper and deeper in
the whole place the funeral homes
already had the layout of the obituaries
they already got them prepped they the
same go grab four or five obituaries
that should start off like the same
he went to this school he did this he
was that he was throwing a what about
when he took grandma on rent money man
i left that [ __ ] out of there yeah
he beat my ass took my money with me i
took my chain all that [ __ ] my boy
johnny was walling johnny was a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
for
he's the greatest thing to happen in
life no this is actually a good
transition so you kind of talked about
it about you know young rappers dying
now like recently too has been a good
amount of guys passing
um
being assaulted yes you're being
assaulted yeah this is crazy [ __ ] going
on like you said there's so much money
to get like what's up like why are we
tripping
what
do you think it's today's hip hop hip
hop or like what is it like what do you
think it is let's go like i said it at
the beginning
energy attract energy yeah that's what
you put out there if you want to if you
if i'm a young cat and i'm in the
streets uh houston i'm in the streets at
compton i'm in the streets of
brownsville i'm in the streets of
baltimore and you telling me that you're
a tough guy you were killing you that
and your raps [ __ ] i'm gonna try you
you know we from there i'm gonna try you
gonna try you yeah i'm gonna try if i'm
gonna do you come through my tail are
you doing the show or if you say some
words against me cause most of the time
you're gonna get tried yeah in a rap
game most people is beefing with people
that's not on a level financially or in
their position they beefing with johnny
from around the way johnny like [ __ ] i
ain't got nothing to live for when i see
you i'ma shoot you yeah
so it's like what the [ __ ] do you do
yeah so it's like you got a energy match
energy it's about an energy exchange so
if you throwing that [ __ ] out there you
i love the dumb [ __ ] oh dumb [ __ ] gonna
find you find you it's gonna find you so
you got to be mindful of the uh of the
messages you put now don't be the energy
don't be rapping about no [ __ ] you
shouldn't be rapping about [ __ ]
hey look look at the camera told him
that don't tell me that i play ball i
don't know
i know that
that's facts that's real i'm telling you
so many dead people out here rapping for
[ __ ] they rap and [ __ ] they shouldn't be
rapping but they never even lived yeah i
know i mean it was like and you're
putting the imagery out there like you
know
and you got a lot of people out there
that love the thing about big and tupac
they were babies yeah they was young
and you never think you never think that
you know how they died so closer than
now it's like dying as a rapper it's
like easy that's like some regular [ __ ]
out here in the side yeah
you know it's easy to die but it's very
difficult to live yeah
you know that's why i never see anybody
that offers themselves a kill i never
say they're weak because it takes a hell
of a person to off themselves you have
to think about it you think right now
i'm off my snow what the [ __ ]
the first time i've ever seen mike was
in philly right
and i was like damn
concrete right there
legends right hey man there you go mike
there you go two good these two good
brothers right here came from prison
right
and started to advertise an agency right
and uh
bragg reached out to me man was like wow
look we got to connect man and that's
what's so great about them man they like
they doing some [ __ ] that nobody do you
wouldn't you ever think about somebody
starting an advertising company on
outside coming home from the joint and
they really connected man
and uh
shout out to them always concrete man
you know i mean from the west side man
west side come on let's see [ __ ] know
concrete come over here man
come on guys right here
y'all being you being too humble over
here brad
i mean
the table or something oh hey man just
sit down man you cool man
actually he wasn't but no you know these
brothers
come to that for me these brothers
always showed me love right man and uh
it's always a great thing and you know
what they even came they even came
they came to philly to show mom i'll
leave love that was major for them to
think while where you at we down here
she dropped the book we all have been
there i'm up in this uh opening package
i'm doing whatever you know cause i
wherever i go at wherever you know just
like y'all i go to help i'm just helping
people you know and then that's when the
first time i seen mike i'm like damn
[ __ ] mike i said mike dang i thought
mike was like you know i mean he might
just come in here all chilling
laid back he chilled he don't say too
much i wanted to speak to him but i'm
like no michael's like you a little too
you know what i mean i'm just saying
i'm like i'm here to help mom i'm here
helping mom [ __ ] all that i speak [ __ ]
was scared to speak to mike
i want to say something about you so you
can still knock me out so i'm gonna
speak from a distance
back then no no no this was when the
book dropped this wasn't back then
that's when it booked you come in there
you come here
mike trying to downplay yeah that's what
i was showing this was six months ago
i might be done so i'm like i'm like
damn i was gonna walk and i'm like
[ __ ] i'm staying over here with mom
and i'm helping open these books and
[ __ ] i'm i'm in there on duty so i'm
like i ain't [ __ ] with mike today and
i mean because he came in they're like
looking around me i'm sorry
i'm like i'm like damn mike hardy [ __ ]
at a book release he wants some brown's
real [ __ ] yeah
he's here
like he walking in childhood you know
the dudes walking the child right [ __ ]
is going on here he's scanning the room
he looking around make sure i don't see
none of my enemies in here he sit down
say oh man
i only got friends [ __ ] yeah but no
shout out in my mind when i'm doing my
road work i'm thinking about [ __ ] up
my enemies in my reality who's my enemy
yeah but it was like uh
shout out to concrete they out here
doing destroying these things they
connect them with a
big corporate america to try to get ad
dollars back into the hood and that's
what it's about you know a lot of people
sell to us but they don't use people
that's us to sell to us and they don't
give these budgets to the people that's
from us and it's like they out here
trying to make to make the plan feel
better and educate people because a lot
of times we see commercials we see ads
pop up and a lot of times them ass is
just targeted to us they're not produced
by people that look like us to
understand the you know uh the language
the the energy they know how to
translate why it's necessary we should
be dealing with certain things so they
just out here changing the game man and
doing things and these brothers was in
prison these brothers come from prison
started an ad agency you something you
hear about the big
agencies sonny and all these different
ones they here they want to move they
making [ __ ] happen man and it's just
great that y'all doing what y'all doing
because in the hood we only look to be
rappers athletes and [ __ ] so y'all
creating a whole new space for the young
kids and giving out opportunities for
people that's coming back re-entering
society they need a shot you know what i
mean for sure that's what it's about man
and i love you all for that man much
love love y'all man like for real when i
told you when i reached out to you
i'm like yo we need to be a part this
got to be a part of the push because
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] built a following
from jail like the [ __ ] came home
running like in the rain like all the
[ __ ] dropping the game yeah well it was
like no we got a plug with you we have
to bro and you ain't like gil y'all got
the shack and cove
it's like when the inspiration the
pictures of y'all in the yard which one
which one is me which one is me i'm
shackle coobie let me see
all right
you're the best ball player in the world
be more like mike and scotty
that's no comparison when you put it
that way though yeah cause i'm like he's
saying i ain't got no money
you say my ball game trash though he
said my i got a [ __ ] basketball wave
i knew he was gonna say that whole
thought wave cat michael who michael who
thought you kept mike the [ __ ] the
the
in the boxing game basketball game it's
the game of life at the end of the game
that we got a master yeah mm-hmm
but it came with life
that's what it's about man but i
appreciate it well it's never mastered
there was nothing wrong with trying
right now
this is beautiful
we got brothers here all of you know he
was all in you know that's four of us in
the inside of that place listen and he's
selling he's selling my man though yeah
mike sell you my man
i love i love that [ __ ] he loves his
mind
listen i mean i'm locked over that he's
the weirdest [ __ ] in the world he's a
[ __ ]
neat freak right
you know ideas himself yeah and i'm
trying to help me say no no no he's not
just doing it right he said no just
leave i've got to just get up so and
he's just particular
he dried the sink out every time he got
wet yes oh yes yeah boys
yes they get up crazy man
uh wax on the floor all that [ __ ] and
listen he's a very humble muslim brother
and one day the guard came into the cell
and he started tossing [ __ ] around
that's the only time in three and a half
years i saw him snap
he's doing five years smoking sales man
yeah
he told me this story one time
about mike talking about when we get
home we going through all this we're
gonna have lambos [ __ ] hey [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] about none of that
[ __ ] i need you to grab the end of the
scene
and help me make this bed up [ __ ] the
he did not give a [ __ ] about that the
lambos and all that [ __ ] missing charlie
but he got it but he did not care for
that moment he just wanted that bad
that's this thing that's it that's
what's really involved man i ain't too
bad for some [ __ ] been to
prison huh no it ain't too bad man just
out here it's not too bad but um it
could be better yes
for the next generation
that's what we're building towards just
your jealous whole purpose is to break
your belief system mm-hmm
you have to break your system you're an
animal almost
and that's his job to kill you either
make you miserable they'd rather you be
miserable than die but they're trying to
do both
gilly i got a question so you were
telling me about how you played ball at
a predominantly white school right
how did you balance that [ __ ] with that
mic to you give a pull the mic close
yeah
how'd you balance that how did you
balance that you loved it didn't you you
loved it honestly be honest
i'm always honest that's the only thing
i know how to you know honestly
i feel like me going to a predominantly
white
college kind of was the kind of the best
thing i ever did in life why is that
because it took it took you took a black
kid that was straight out the hood all
he knew was black black black everything
was black black school all black school
all black neighborhood all black friends
all everything and then when you took me
out of that environment and put me in a
total different environment
it taught me how to how to adapt in life
around anybody
you know what i'm saying yeah
and it taught me that how to be myself
around anybody white black blue brown
orange it didn't matter
i'm just i'm always just going to beat
me you know what i'm saying
so
it really it helped me for the future
you feel what i'm saying as far as how
do you explain you
how do i you're gonna always be how do
you explain that how do you explain you
being you i mean
finding out you know when you're young
you don't really know who you are you
know you be trying to aim sometimes i
still don't know yeah you know
but you gotta you got a better knowledge
and you're closer to finding out who you
are than you was back then huh i don't
know
i learned bigger words from back then
but
i'm still really behind and really find
out who the hell i am yeah yeah well
your words are bigger but the distance
is still the same
that might be the truth
yeah
you think so
it might be i forget about the girl
right there beautiful stuff man god
willing he continues to make this you
know i
i feel like you know
it it helped me you know
longer later down the line that you know
just be comfortable yeah you know as far
as being and like i got friends right
now that
you know
that they still live in all
everything's all black you know you take
them in front in a room full of all
white people and it's like they not even
themselves yeah i'm gonna climb up you
know what i mean it's like he's sitting
in there he's walking around like
hey how you doing my name's jamal [ __ ]
your name jamal i didn't even know that
bullet head
your name was bullet head and since i
met you
like crazy mike your name was yeah we
were going a room full of white people
your name jamal yeah
oh [ __ ] i'm founding out as they're
fighting there you know what i'm saying
my boy got two aliases for me you know
it just it just i just feel like it
helped me get get around but you know
what was special about that you were
just saying
they're conscious that they're ignorant
how many people you know is conscious
then
right
yep
so they were special people they weren't
[ __ ]
right something to do
that's a hell of a tourniquet conscience
that they ignore right because you get
into an environment that's not your
environment and you don't want to be
bullet head no more
you want to beat jamal
i like bullet head
he said i'm just now finding out your
name is jamal
what are you doing
you know what happened
he got
right you never knew that and then it'd
be some nice and neat [ __ ]
yeah dude be deep you know no then you
get locked up with your man and you like
your name is jermaine gutierrez you like
jermaine gutierrez [ __ ] you
spanish yeah yeah
spaniard
street actually i'm from nicaragua but
you know
we got different binoculars
okay the street names is different black
is the eighth of fade too man yeah
all right but before we end this before
we end this that ain't anything
we got to end this [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay all right all right say let's keep
going now that's right you got it
that's [ __ ] up when you do you just
gotta bow out like
keep on [ __ ] and this need to be told
that people need to know this that
there's people out in the world that's
the whole consistency of life is to help
people right
i know you're looking at them think that
uh that they had their day but their
whole purpose now is to help people yeah
they talking to facebook and google and
negotiating things for you know for the
people that you know
the world forgot about you know it's a
bunch of people that the world forgot
about y'all but then i gonna forget
about them now yeah
that's why these gentlemen are here yeah
i appreciate that's what it's about yeah
that's connected man and the call i
remember they called me one time
put me in the line with some people from
facebook right i'm like you know from
facebook
they got me they're like yeah why do we
like your stuff i'm like he's like no
just facebook facebook i said
facebook facebook yeah they breaking my
stuff down yeah we what's the name fire
we got to do something we got to figure
it out
i'm telling all these dudes that walk
the yard these dudes that uh a piece of
paper might say that there's something
else than what they really are because
we never get a shot when that paperwork
comes through whoa once that paperwork
once that paperwork hit and it ain't dry
on that paper you in that system a lot
of times a lot of people never could
come back from that and don't get a shot
because that documentation will
follow you it'll follow you and you'll
grow outside of that that individual
that you was when the paper when it
ain't dry you'll become something else
and now it's like oh no you can't kill
that person you steal that person and
we're gonna make sure you steal that
person cause we're gonna put you in
conditions and send you back to the
environment that produced that person
even though you might have elevated so
you take a lot of you got to really be
strong to be able to say tomorrow's
gonna be better than yesterday and try
to do new things and be brave enough to
say you know what
i know i don't i don't know too much
about this field but i know enough right
and i know that they they commercials
ain't gonna never die i know advertising
ain't gonna never die and i know that we
need a place up in here
and uh that's major man that's a major
[ __ ] i remember when i was first in
prison and when i first got there i was
a thick guy i was just mad fighting kick
and everything and then a year and a
half goes by hey i'm i'm uh
i win the
perfect um prisoner award or whatever it
is a guy
and everybody loves me now i got a
girlfriend that's one of the um
the guards
everybody loved me now i don't want to
even go home no more
and man i'm just thinking to myself why
would i want to go home dude i have this
right here right but anyway
that part of my life was just um
if i didn't go to prison i'd be dead
that's the best part oh the best thing
ever happened to me all my friends were
dying
so prison was the best thing that ever
happened to me
and i had to um i had fun too but this
is what i wanted to stay remember when i
went there before i got cool became the
dawn there i got into a couple of
write-ups and so while i'm doing this
now i'm getting ready to go home
in a month they say hey cam come over
here you're a hell of a guy but you know
remember in the beginning we had to
write you up and we added another year
too you lost some good times yeah oh
[ __ ] up your girl but the guy's my
friend on week after i used to fight
with him but after before we became
friends he would bring me food and stuff
and they said hey remember that early
and when you first came here you know
write up he said hey i have to give you
an extra year but i know you can work it
off i believe in you mike
i'm saying
that
but before we after we had that on the
occasion we were like best friend he
would bring me food from on the street
and they go oh remember you were acting
out when you first got here
all the helicopters you hear in the
prison they're waiting for the all the
lights they're waiting for you to come
out and i was already institution i had
my girlfriend there we were chilling out
i would pay for a house and everything
you know it was all good right now you
got to go and it was it was frightening
for me to leave damn it it was
frightening you go there all the cameras
see you planes everywhere
just like a piece of meat
yeah i was i was safer in prison
listen i win i went in this deal
in prison i was worth like 300 million
dollars out in the street what's up
next thing you know you're worth two
dollars
you know that's tricky it's
tricky yeah
did you feel that uh why would you feel
that uh
lostness when you when you came out like
or no because you were so educated like
you were so excited
that [ __ ] no
i hit the ground but like people don't
understand like for me and i know for a
lot of the homeboys i knew the most
scariest day in prison is the day you
got to leave because everything that
[ __ ] bad [ __ ] that you
said you was to your family your grandma
on the phone yeah grandma i changed mom
i swear i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do
that you got to be that [ __ ] now that
[ __ ] you said you was and now
you go home you're like
and you're like oh [ __ ] i really gotta
go out here in the combat and figure it
out you know when you you know an
average person might not be like me
might not be like mike i might not be
like whereas though they really got to
go out there hit the ground running and
try to get a real job yeah and
when the no's come is you going to chase
them yes and say damn you know what i
got 15 knows but it might be 15 yeses
i'll do my name on it so the average
person that [ __ ] might trigger him when
the nose hit man [ __ ] it i'm going to
get high on [ __ ] i'm going to go get
a package oh [ __ ] i'm going back to
get with the homies
because it's like man [ __ ] because it's
already marketed that you ain't got a
chance when you come home from jail so
now [ __ ] like damn
i went the rite aid i went to whole
foods he said no [ __ ] get out of here i
went here uh so it was like
i made the block the homie holiday the
homie said he got that package
homie like what's up
i'm living them in creative with my mom
or my grandma or my girl my girl might
be like
hey baby don't worry about nothing
a month mutt and a half come around that
ring like damn [ __ ] what you gonna do
dude yeah you know what you know you
gotta hear i'm pregnant listen i'm
pregnant um
one thing about assistant she just got
she's gonna say some [ __ ] that you need
you know like i'm saying you laying up
in this [ __ ] eating all this
food like what you doing yeah are you
eating up you drinking rahim juicy
juices
you got different you got different
appetites when you're in jail you work
in the kitchen a [ __ ] jail go
down the kitchen and eat a loaf of bread
mm-hmm like it ain't nothing so you come
back in there you you putting dents in
loaf of bread you need a half a box of
cereal yeah he's like your meals is
stronger yeah eating five and a half
oodles of noodles you know what i mean
using everything you're doing all this
dumpster in the crib you got you you got
your road boy you got you you got your
flip-flop you got anything you went
there comfortable yeah she like hold up
i keep going she going she's a nursing
aide or whatever she's gonna come back
and work you lay it up in there like
this feed up all the bread and go dad
she come home you want to [ __ ] get your
dick sucking off she like and then she
hit you with that joint like uh like
what you doing like when like when you
gonna start bringing some money in here
and that [ __ ] hit you in your heart it
hit you in your heart deep no you never
heard this one hey if you don't give me
no money i'm gonna take the babies and
go to welfare oh it's a wrap
and you don't have any money but i i
don't know how i managed to get twenty
thousand over there but there's one
[ __ ]
i don't know how that happened you made
it the [ __ ] happened yeah yeah when they
say that if you don't give me no money
i'm going i'm gonna take the kids i'm
going to stand them well for the life
wow that should be hard these watchers
got to go home
somebody got to go that should be real
man but you know
it's what it is it's life man and we all
living and trying to figure this [ __ ]
out as we go
you know true and we got to start
putting each other on though i think
that's that's a huge thing like
when we talk about
we always was raised don't introduce
nobody to your plug what i learned from
white folks in the corporate world
they'd be like you got to meet my friend
vincent he's amazing like no they'll put
you in a group text and a heartbeat so
i'll be like yo how do i do that [ __ ]
for my people you know what i'm saying
follow yeah y'all want to do something
about what okay crabs on the birthday
that's how you do that everybody this is
no y'all don't even know everybody in
the culture when y'all don't see you
guys are embraced no this is how you get
this stuff you guys have to have annual
meetings
i'll have annual picnics or something
entertainment where you all can get
together then eventually you're gonna
have a little talk and then work it out
there eventually um it'll be big talking
big businesses it's all about getting to
know one another every one of you all
all of the rich guys all know about each
other but they have never met each other
they want to meet each other but they
don't they got ego they don't want to
say hey i'm bob so you want somebody
that has
relationships yeah and to do something
yeah i learned that you know i'm around
all these rich rich white guys and they
they're not friendly to each other you
know the only way they're friendly is
for me i didn't know me and they they
never talk to they all know who each
other is from the corporation but they
never talked to each other before
and then i think that's what we should
do we should always have
um some kind of
we're talking par with one another we
should always talk to each other
about investments everything it's just
like having the team
like what's the play what should we be
doing mm-hmm yeah where y'all at what
y'all trying to do oh i got somebody for
that i got the truth and then i got
something our boys should be in we
should have somebody in the stock market
and they just should be giving us the
numbers we should always be able to talk
everybody should always be work be
willing to talk to each other we don't
have that everybody wants to do but they
have no
way of doing it no way of being
introduced to one another that's what i
see
everybody wants to know each other but
they don't know how to they don't want
that
yeah they don't want to go but they're
going to think they're weak if they go
yeah crying
that's real that's real but fellaini so
shallow
it is it's real but it's
it is shallow but i also think you know
uh eagle's the enemy you know what i
mean like eagles enemies to a certain
degree a certain degree when he start
when he's when you start listening to
him then he's the enemy
it's facts
well wallow gilly thank you so much it's
really awesome she was awesome
i never knew was gonna come to this kind
of depth
you know i just saw you in there
bullying people on television
i see them spiking spiking the bosses
right where the arabs were spanish guys
what were they some arabs what was it
he was spanish
before we end this i'm talking about the
guy that ran the store the arabs for the
arab slap it was just a slap but it
wasn't nothing it wasn't that but it was
really disrespectful smack it it was
smack wait if he if
he's back to me i would come back
he said it was disgusting it was you
shouldn't do that to a human being
that was no listen because he played the
role of a really ruthless [ __ ]
yeah he has played that role that's why
he didn't like him after that [ __ ]
that guy's ass in the store
[ __ ]
stay out the way hey
well there you have it
you heard it here first
stay off them streets don't get shot
make your bread stay safe
please this is hot boxing with mike
tyson i'm bash the co-host swallow and
gilly are getting the crew thank you
create don't forget concrete next
yeah yes sir thank you so much helping
people of color yes sir we really
appreciate it appreciate you all for
having us wishing you nothing but
continued success and blessings
what do you want to say to those people
um
it's never too late to be great and
tomorrow's going to be better than
yesterday i come from a place where as
though i was counted out
early in the game a lot of us here on
this oh right here was counted out but
we figured out a way to make it uh
believe in yourself don't be entitled go
out there and put that hard work in and
uh the workers win in the end right the
people that's willing to work the people
that's willing to develop themselves and
realize that they don't know anything
and the people that's willing to learn
if you're willing to learn out there you
got a [ __ ] shot and uh one of the
biggest things i can tell you is [ __ ]
what they think
don't base your life off of somebody
else don't don't let somebody else
opinion be a remote control to your life
don't be pimped by people future
perceptions of you get out there [ __ ]
live the way you know how to live i
can't tell you how to live mike can't
tell you how to live kind of create
can't tell you how to live you know uh
and if you feel it you [ __ ] live it
it's just like that
just like just like that
[Music]
you